[Music]
i'll bring that face over
way back
[Music]
way back
[Music]
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by
support the fight go buy some
merchandise at the shop
it's a great conversation starter and
irritates
all the right people.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
delicious oh boy that's really loud i
think the intro is a little lower and
the the mics here are a little loud but
uh it's raining cats and dogs it is
right there yeah it's raining which i
don't know
i don't know where that term came from
cats and dogs doesn't make a whole lot
of sense but really far from this i just
realized i took a big sip i don't know
if you can see there's a bunch of
sediment in there that's really
disgusting yeah water
i spit it yeah it looks like probably
bernie when bernie sanders goes to
starbucks because he doesn't tip
him steven just return bernie sanders
visit hey
really glad to uh be here with you now
it's it's weird being on youtube
it it it is a little bit we did it one
time last week
so far we're still here we are right
yeah
but it is pride month yes yep for now
which also happens to go inside with
cultural appropriation month
so anything can happen uh and of course
you can follow us over there
at mug club we have a lot to talk about
today we're gonna talk about the nfl new
wokeness how they're uh
uh oh they're doing anti-racism in the
nfl which i thought when you had seventy
percent
i mean like i mean i could understand if
the nhl
needed to have that one need something
yeah right you need to walk if it's true
or perhaps lacrosse
the nfl nba i don't really think that we
need to necessarily change the demo i
think you're doing pretty good
uh and we'll also be talking about the
esg a lot of people realize this the
credit score of companies a lot of you
don't necessarily know why
some of this wokeness is happening there
is something going on behind the scenes
that's a a
little more involved and of course the
the h3h3 productions i guess decided to
address us and uh
it is appointed to a man once to be
addressed and invited onto this program
and then we can never address him again
namely because we'll try and get us
banned you know with susan which is oh
of course they're all buddies so
i'll have to get to look we have uh
gerald how are you i'm well how are you
i'm okay there you go how are you
quarterback hey i'm doing good
doing good so you went the other way you
went to three quarters today i went the
other way
you know i got to spread it out i got
the shirt for the other quarters oh very
nice
you should you know you should make uh
make some uh some uh some samples for
nancy pelosi she can wrap it around her
face
yeah and uh dave landau's here ahoy how
are you
i'm good how about you you know live i i
had
the baby shower and all of my wife's
cousins and family
were over and it's enough of that i
helped very some of them back to the
house yeah it's enough it would be there
it's just i can't
i can do gift cards i have no idea what
i got
oh it's i have no clue what oh my gosh
you didn't get anything but no i didn't
get anything
it's always like those guys you know
well probably like h3h3 they probably
said like we're pregnant
i know everything i need to know about
you no we're pregnant
really you're pregnant you're with child
but now you know men can breastfeed too
and uh women use men's razors and their
mustaches so
this is where we are hey before we get
to anything else antifa
um this just happened over the weekend i
believe ant activists
uh were protesting they showed up and
couldn't even remember
the name of the person for whom they're
out protesting
stay here show like but we're holding
space
obviously for i'm not gonna lie foreign
all right so we're here you know showing
us all day for
winston smith another i didn't i didn't
even know about it
behind him so is unicorn right abandoned
shut up in there
his name is winston smith don't forget
that name winston smith
say his name make sure y'all remember
this because we're going to say his name
because i can't remember him yeah i left
for george it's i've never seen a more
clear example of him repeating it to
himself
exactly winston smith yeah you remember
that i remember
winston smith which has two vowels
and uh winston smith you didn't remember
that isn't that right
yeah i need sanctuary um
i've read that in a book you have to say
it thrice yeah six times i'll never
forget it
yeah winston smith man it would have
been better if i didn't micro dose them
shrooms
winston what churchill scott son of a
[ __ ]
yeah my face is melting i'll go steal
some races at a walgreens and call them
racist
um hey by the way really quick let me
just let you know about this too some
people were confused last week
why this happened so let me just show
you cnn right live and you'll notice
that if we go to cnn right now we bring
it up live um it's like
five or ten seconds delayed so we have
here because
we don't know the policies with youtube
and we've read the policies but they
don't enforce them consistently
we have uh what is the youtube dump
button so if anyone says something here
for example last week people thought the
show was over
gerald had the gall to discuss someone
else
saying that a mask you know a nurse was
saying that a mask
uh if you touched your face and you
touched a door for a disease
so another nurse who was totally in the
wrong right uh said that and because
that would go against
youtube's guidelines right that's
whenever you see
this which for people on mug club this
is playing for
about five seconds right now and then
it's going to end right about here
uh see now we're back on youtube that
means that someone said something that
really isn't offensive but isn't allowed
on youtube
just so you know but it's always
available on my club that's right so we
have to have that now as a failure too
spicy for youtube
isn't it crazy you have to be the fcc
you knew the rules
there's no gatekeeper and now it's like
you can't say
that the world health organization gets
things wrong and i was so pissed last
week when we were talking about this and
it wasn't anybody here i was like i
can't believe that that
might possibly like living in a world
where what i said last week could
possibly get you banned from youtube
well you are
you are the poster boy for aryan well
well
it's basically it's basically matt and
then gerald
yeah it's carlin's seven dirty words or
an opinion
right yes yes or no or actually just
quoting
medical facts or quoting their misquotes
from two weeks ago
at least with the fcc i remember when i
was in the fcc when i was on a radio
show you know syndicated yeah
and i said can i i went and i said can i
call obama prick they said yeah you can
you can't you just can't say that uh
obama has a small prick i'm like okay
well that's fine good
they we knew the rules right it was very
you know the line yeah
they said you can call him a dumb you
can call him a [ __ ]
right but you can't say barack obama
shits right because that's scatological
so we knew the rules they were silly
but we understood them but no radio
station no television program
would have ever removed you or hit the
sensor button because you're saying hey
you know what i think the world health
organization was wrong when they said
that uh kovet couldn't transmit human to
human
the little indian popped up i didn't do
that
just shuts off plays the star spangled
banner it's just over that's just
roseanne
come on i thought the [ __ ] was white
um by the way you can follow me on
instagram as we go on here and uh the
best thing you can do
it's a it's a weekly show it's about say
thursday show oh yeah it's a daily show
monday's on thursday 10 a.m eastern so
you don't need to worry about
notifications you can watch them upload
if you watch here you can watch over on
rumble
um do not let us lose touch with you uh
okay
and i do have some questions for you i
do want to know why you guys think
all of these corporations are are going
in full woke despite it actually hurting
their pocketbook yeah
uh before we get to that though oh my
gosh
i got this this was sent to me from an
angry veteran yes and i will tell you
this i get like veterans will come up at
shows i don't know if you've had this
yet where like people have given me
like their navy cross or something or
like yeah a guy had a coin for me just
the other day and a few other things
yeah and i just
i don't because it's you know you want
to respect it but you also don't really
i already have some on display i don't
have room for it
and i don't want to reject it yeah you
know so i just keep i basically have a
drawer
with these metals that i have no
business owning and i really appreciate
it but please people stop
keep it give it to your grandkids
because it's going in a drawer there my
shelf has no more space how where am i
going to keep mike tyson's biography
it's true very important so um veterans
sent this to me
i got a folded flag for real yeah i got
a golden flag too and then i got some
anyway i had a neighbor who got mad
because our flag is old
ah and they said this is someone
anonymously said that's disrespectful
it's like oh oh
crazy [ __ ] you haven't heard of ragged
old flag yeah
it makes you look cooler crying out loud
that's the beauty of it it's an old flag
uh okay so anyway but i had veterans who
were furious about this
yeah brian williams remember when brian
williams was thought of as a journalist
i just love that he went to msnbc
because that's everyone who is currently
at msnb
currently at nbc they think like brian
williams at msnbc but they just
they don't say the quiet part out loud
it's like you go there and you get
canceled from honesty
right yes exactly yeah
um so he compared the allied troops of
d-day
yeah in normandy to
antifa he said that they just watched
this and i had so many veterans send me
letters and the folks at the lincoln
project are out with a reminder to all
who is antifa they stormed the beaches
of normandy
parachuted into the french countryside
and gave their lives to face down
and fight back against fascism
they took down nazi machine gunness tore
apart the third reich's strongholds
[Music]
machine gunness italy belgium holland
anywhere antifa saw fascism they
fearlessly
and relentlessly send in the
purple-haired lesbian down into that
trench see how it works out i was
defeated
because of patriots like these proud
americans
a war we still fight today
oh still against donald trump yeah where
do you see the american flags at rallies
who wears the american flag pin
who actually pulled down american flags
and
monuments to the interval let's not act
as a come on it's
everything about that is fantastic
except for the commentary and opinions
yes absolutely and claiming and claiming
that antifa today would be fighting
against fascism by using
fascism right right silencing political
opinions and othering people who
disagree and getting rid of them that's
exactly what mussolini did you did look
up the definition lincoln project well
they're stepping on a swastikan the
other example is the last president
right right yeah great good one yeah
exactly the guy who had a
jewish son-in-law and was the single
biggest supporter of israel of any
modern presidents yeah but they signed
up with the uh the islamic states who by
the way if you look back into the uh the
nazi regime look and see what a lot of
these middle eastern
arabic countries where they lined up
they they hate the jews too you hate
jews
we hate jews you hate jews because of
mohammed well because of us it's because
i'm a pagan well you know different
strokes but we all hate jews yes that's
correct
besties and no one ever wants to talk
about it no one wants to talk about it
and by the way
it's there's still i would argue there
are still remnants of that in the middle
east but
remnants you know but also that was from
the lincoln project i need to
to note so brian williams was showing
that from the lincoln project who
were they remember the lincoln project
they were a republican organization and
then they you know
there's a pedophile organization and now
they're just you know anti-trump
um but tomorrow was actually a one-year
anniversary of chas in seattle
by current antifa i remember very well
and so they didn't show this on brian
williams but coming out today we
actually have i think an exclusive
uh the other the new lincoln project uh
video on antifa today who is
antifa in 2020 they stormed the city of
seattle
and created the autonomous zone jazz
but then change the name to chop because
they needed stuff
stuff like cafe lattes gluten-free bread
and super cool sunglasses
in the last year and a half all over
this country
everywhere antifa saw fascism they
relentlessly annihilated it
in minneapolis they liberated a black
firefighter from his bar
in new york they freed shop owners from
their goods
and in a well-to-do suburb of detroit
this soldier told his mom to
shut the [ __ ] up stupid when she asked
him to please wear a jacket
because it was getting chilly out
fascism was almost defeated because of
patriots like
antifa but fascism still exists today
and the fight against it is still strong
anti-fascism isn't just a cable news
talking point
it's an american ideal that should be
memorialized
because it was paid for in blood
and skateboards
[Music]
you know sometimes you don't realize you
mock something you don't realize who you
heard yeah moving no i shed a tear yeah
you don't realize who you hurt now i
know hey we're also going to we're going
to be talking about h3h2 which would be
fun but
before that this uh went really viral uh
yesterday
um i don't know why anyone watched it
but logan paul fought floyd mayweather
and uh we just have to touch on it real
quick there's some things that you may
have missed it's time for our asian
sports correspondent to break it down
[Music]
all right junior choi how are you sir
i'm doing good stephen how are you
i'm okay and you're a fan of combat
sports i guess yeah i actually
enjoy a good fight every now and then
yeah do you yeah well you're you're
korean right so you
yeah yeah i did a little bit taekwondo
when i was younger so real experienced
in a little fighting you throw a mean
kick
i think so okay well yeah that means no
that's enough
that's a hard pass so for people who
didn't tune in this was uh a youtuber
you know jake
logan paul and i will say this i give
the guy respect for getting in the ring
obviously yes but he's doing the work
there was no story to be told here
because everyone knew it was the best
defensive boxer of all time floyd wade
ali tyson no one's even close versus a
guy who's fought three times and i think
lost twice
uh and so it ended exactly how you
thought it would end but you were saying
there's more to the story here though in
breaking it down
yeah so like obviously like for those of
you know like the fight went for
eight rounds without a knockout so that
was actually surprising like a huge
upset he was there but when the bell was
ringing
yeah exactly and there were no judges or
anything so no one kept track of the
scores because it was an exhibition
match so it doesn't go on either of
their records
right but yeah so but the important part
here is that
like the the riveting part about this is
their defensive strategy right the
defensive yeah exactly what is known as
a defensive boxer
exactly so let's go into the first clip
here okay
so you can tell that they haven't seen
each other in a while they're excited
clearly happy to be together obvious
chemistry right there look at them
together right
um yeah i suppose is that and right
there there it is
perfect technique paul's got his fist
gently on the small
of mayweather's back yeah i don't know
okay caressing i don't know about the
relevance of you know the time apart but
mm-hmm so this is the heart grow fonder
technique yeah i mean like it's more of
like a loving embrace like
paul's got his arm underneath okay kind
of holding there okay yeah well none of
us are boxers really so you're breaking
it down okay
defense all right right now let's get
into the second clip actually okay we'll
get more of it
in here yeah so you can see here that
the loins are burning here stephen okay
now this is a really good hug
very personal right in paul's ear
mayweather is letting him know
i can't i can't quit you just flawless
defensive test yeah i don't think yeah
okay i don't i'm not entirely sure that
you really
are combat sports adept this is but you
can clearly see that they are like
loving each other like loving him i
think there's professional admiration
for competition disrespect i don't know
about an angley line
you know what let's get into the final
clip and finally right here very good
here
so this is brilliant that's the
defensive technique being used here by
both fighters
they're clearly touching tips
they're not touching tips at all no no
no gloves gerald gloves
tips the tips of the gloves clearly
they're going to spend many happy years
together and i for one couldn't be more
excited for their future together
really but yeah you can't teach better
defensive technique than this stephen
actually i believe you can all right
asian sports corporate you've helped
zero
[Music]
all right i feel informed though i don't
i yeah i don't good fight as a matter of
fact i now feel
less safe
did you at least think he could karate i
feel like i feel like if you're going to
deconstruct
com com the art of combat you need to
to reconstruct it with something useful
he just deconstructed it and left it
there like tinker toys that someone got
bored with
nothing useful at all gay tinker toys
all right he did a good job
so uh by the way best thing you can do
is just comment
comment below we're going to be talking
about h3 and i want to hear from what do
you think is going on right now
with gay pride like it's one thing to
keep but all of these corporations going
all in and at the same time uh obviously
calling
the basic id requirements for voting to
be uh
voter suppression it is it's almost like
you know with
with banning donald trump at facebook
twitter youtube
the same thing with alex jones and got
rid of his podcast like did they have a
meeting
did everybody have a meeting and say the
sexual preference is the thing we need
like memorial day we
we just jumped right past that yeah oh
yeah it just jumps right into
sexualization of children and other
things that we think are highly
highly important to do for an entire
month with the cheerios and the
fruitless half the movie on the
movies on the plane that i was on which
was actually one of them was brokeback
yeah we're saying who's sitting down to
go well what's this cowboy movie
and just like playing on this planet i
feel really bad for the person who's
like well i liked unforgiving this yeah
this is a western drifter sort of a
spiritual component oh my god
what nah it just spit that's not
realistic at all is that
cousin eddie on horseback watching them
in a tent oh chief
what the heavens just my goodness
palm is inconsiderate it's crazy because
they do beep
it's it's for it's visual but they take
out the swearing
but they leave every bit of gore
violence and sex on the screen oh wow so
whenever i watch anything and people are
having sex i'm like
can people see this on this it's just a
hardcore sex scene and he's like
yeah i'm enjoying filleting fish
with you that's not the part that was
most concerning
no and it's not the part that makes me
embarrassed that someone is sitting in a
middle seat yeah just sew my socks
so my socks
[Laughter]
we're like in uh face off when they had
it on tv i remember it was a nice case
she's like
forget you what that's not good because
the kid's going to grow up thinking
that's what it means
right exactly forget you dad babe you
want to forget
all right let's go here now you know
about this i know nothing about sports
you you don't right so i mean it don't
matter
the nfl now you were you were in a tizzy
about this yeah nfl is doing this thing
called it's called
they're halting race norming yeah in a
billion dollar settlement
yeah i don't even know what this means i
kind of thought that sports
were one of the things that obviously
minorities not not asians
but you know black people when we say
minorities black americans
felt like they got a decent shake well
you would think so right so
last week the nfl pledged to end race
norming like you said
uh the practice of assuming black
players start off with
a lower iq and reading this is like
crazy well that doesn't sound like they
shouldn't do that they shouldn't right
and they're basically doing that when
determining
kind of the compensation for brain
issues right or injuries that they maybe
had from getting hit too many times
which obviously happens in the nfl okay
and this move was part of a one billion
dollar settlement for brain injury
claims
race norming made it more difficult for
black players to show a deficit
and qualify for relief that sounds that
sounds to me like
it actually i will say this i really see
this on the show that sounds kind of
racist
yes for the nfl to do that 100 correct
how much of that curve was thrown off by
vince young who scored lower than
statistical random on the qb test
well and like you said close to three
quarters of them are black they might
take offense
yeah you know i just doesn't seem like a
good way to run your league their
workforce might be a little i hope
oj gets a giant check
he's like
like the ones adam sandler got on the
golf course that kind of okay anyway
the nfl don't worry though that you know
like you said sounds pretty bad but
don't worry they're still woke they also
just revealed their new pride
logo what uh yeah so they have a pride
logo and they tweeted the new rainbow
logo red and
i'll just quote it for you here happy
pride month the nfl is proud to unveil
our new nfl pride shield to show
our support and solidarity with the
lgbtq plus community
we stand with lgbtq plus people this
month and year long with a commitment to
our players our fans and our staff to
live proudly and
authentically unless of course you
happen to be black
and have a brain injury and we think you
start off stupider than white people now
let me tell you this
some people may say oh well this was
just a medical thing that they did to
determine kind of a baseline for
dementia
and that's true but maybe the cognitive
ability test that you gave them when
they came into the league
would be a better way to use this
because you can have idiots and savants
in different categories of race it
doesn't matter if they're black white or
hispanic
two people brought suit against this
because they said if they had been white
and the nfl agreed they would have
received a claim but because they were
black
and race norming was used they didn't
receive a claim and it's five hundred
thousand dollars to start with
and if you have kind of a more severe
case of dementia it's seven also
this sounds so bad that i don't that i
almost don't believe it i feel like i
need to do some more digging like
like maybe rainstorming is just a claim
but it didn't actually happen sorry guys
we got to give the
white people more money what's the
problem why are you all mad
exactly that would be redistribution in
the nfl for sure
it would be like look come on there are
not enough white people are not paid
nearly enough i know you can throw out
tom brady and a couple of mannings
outside of that
yeah come on well in the nfl recently
defended this so to your point saying oh
this is probably no no they recently
defended this thing that it actually
hadn't harmed anybody and then they came
back and
well you know uh our bad so that's how
it wasn't just leo's speech from django
let me explain i'm just going that's
good they know their audience now the
lgbtq i tell you what though that
wouldn't be bad just get on the o line
and write right before you're about to
face up write a left card just go
yeah i want to forget you huh right
done why is there a pride shield i bet
anybody in high school who was getting
stuffed in their locker by a football
player wishes they had a shield
i don't think that's happening anymore i
think it's the pri it's i think right
now in school if you if you are gay or
if you are trans
it is carte blanche you you will get in
trouble
zero zero and you can say whatever you
want like that guy uh
called me uh the f word suspended
get off the team yeah all right okay
so uh i don't usually like doing this
but uh uh
and things have changed because uh ethan
klein character h3
uh i guess brought on a lawyer which oh
a pro youtube corporate which we're not
gonna get into because look i'm not
going to do anything legal in the court
of public opinion let's
let that happen in the courts but
there's this uh program and people have
been asking us to address it uh eight
and you may not be familiar with it uh
h3h3 the guy's name is ethan and
we laughed not long ago about him
saying that people shouldn't think about
critical scientific and medical issues
this was the clip which got him upset
i don't think i've ever seen a more
perfect encapsulation
of group think and discouraging
any sort of critical thinking whatsoever
and
laughing about it with no self-awareness
this is my favorite clip
of the year let's roll it they said you
gotta wear a mask so i'm out there
wearing a mask
wow big deal and then now they say you
know if you're outside you don't need to
wear a mask
it's pretty simple you want to talk
about who's dumb
yeah i mean there's a whole there's a
whole the cdc is like this whole
governmental body
with scientists and they just tell us
what to do you don't have to think about
it dude
[Laughter]
after dark okay again look and i still
think it's funny i've never seen
anybody so smug about being so ignorant
now
let me be clear of course we had some
fun but was criticizing the idea i do
think it's a bad thing
to tell people out there young
impressionable people because you know
especially when you have audience an
audience who's like nine years old when
you've had to adapt your content to be
youtube friendly
to tell them not to think critically now
to be clear
we usually go after uh political figures
science authoritative sources right on
this show usually those are the people
who
have to debate change my mind is not a
debate but we've had politicians
scientists pulitzer winners uh and every
now and then
a layup crosses our our path who you
know we just
just kind of like the stick that you're
only capable of h3h3
right that's the only thing you can do
is is do the youtube drama
so um apparently some didn't like it had
some harsh criticism
for me namely ethan and uh
he had this criticism uh to issue about
us again not being smart enough to think
critically and
double down on the fact that one
shouldn't
i'm so stupid why is he questioning uh
any like the cdc or fouchy yeah
seriously bro
you're not a doctor i don't even know i
don't want to think about things bro
do you [ __ ] question like dead on him
let's say the the
the uh god is so dumb it's like so
so dumb dude do you go to the doctor and
then he
i literally can't do you go to the
pharmacy and overlook their
like oh is that the right medicine yes
yes i do you know what i'm saying like
once
you give me the wrong medication i had
my doctor make sure they got the right
one you don't need to [ __ ]
do i read labels and you don't
then you should be listening to dr fauci
and the
and the cds okay good think about it
dude exactly
it's that simple just don't think don't
do it it's got electrolytes
imagine you couldn't you wouldn't even
have to make this video if you just
didn't even think about it
you're doubling downer than you that
dedicated their whole life to scientific
research
you look at all the stress and strain on
him that could have been prevented
you're so stressed i don't even have to
think about it feel the stress and
strain on me that you know make
me gray and walking recessive genetic
polymorphism uncapable of
growing contractile tissue it's taking
its toll
it's like it's almost like you were me
pre benjamin button
okay it's like when you hear two people
talk at a party and you know they're
wrong about something but you just don't
get involved because you don't want them
in your life
stay far away no look let me be really
clear okay
this is i understand what you're saying
shitty conversations starbucks
i understand what you're saying there
and of course you need to trust
you need to aggregate and verify i never
claim to be a doctor
that's why we have them on our show
that's why we provide the sources that
we do however
yes i do read labels of pills that i
take and for example talking about like
supplements
yeah i make sure it's gmp certified or i
make sure that it's nsf certified
especially when i used to compete
because you have to make sure that this
thing isn't tainted
not saying that doesn't make me a
supplement manufacturer it makes me
cautiously skeptical and by the way this
is what matters
the cdc he just said fouchy in the cdc i
mean the fact that look
ethan ethan the fact that you're not
aware i guess of the fouchy emails and
the fact that he was telling the people
one thing
while believing another behind the
scenes and this has been released this
should tell you that trusting
one person blindly is a problem let's
just go through some examples
of where we criticize and i know that
you're pro youtube banning and d
platforming we'll get to that in a
second because
one of our warnings was we accurately
cited the cdc data but they didn't like
that we did
um let's go to the cdc okay one let's go
to example one you have a cdc you have
world health organization
in january the world health organization
said there was no evidence of human
human transmission
that was echoed by the cdc okay january
2021 the cdc published a
a a journal in jama claiming that nearly
60 percent of covid cases came from
asymptomatic carriers
then in april different cdc study found
that asymptotic carriers were unlikely
to substantially contribute to the
pareto spread of code
this just happened i believe today or
yesterday yes california
the scientists don't even listen bro
don't have to think about it dude
so so [ __ ] stupid bro look they just
reduced their death rate by 25 percent
in california because
it's a lot whoopsie we had it wrong
and something that you need to
understand i'm not saying that in all of
these now in these instances
i was right because i said i think it
can transmit to humans and
for example we said i think you can't
trust the world health organization
because
you know they work with china they're
very close and it seems like there might
be a lab leak we were correct but
science
isn't governed it's not determined by
consensus
it's determined by what's true and
that's why you have different scientific
voices
you trust only the cdc and fauci we
aggregate fauci cdc world health
organization
other doctors and qualified
immunologists epidemiologists and yes
that's a difference
in a world view that i have so fouchy's
emails right here that in case you
didn't know i don't think that he
remembers
but yeah said he had uh emails saying
masks weren't effective the mass sold at
drug stores
he also denied gain of function research
even though we know that from the emails
that he actually did know about it
um and of course the funding to the
wuhan lab there are a lot of things that
happened
that they were just misleading about so
i don't know why you would simply trust
a government entity and be so
smug about people who think critically
and by the way
we'll also get to the point that we
provide references and sources
so that everyone else can educate
themselves which you've never done you
just go so
so [ __ ] stupid bro i'm going to call
a youtube executive
to get them banned because it's like
borderline dude that's what they're
trying to do is get you thrown off
yeah of course absolutely that's always
nice when content creators side with
corporations of course
to get people removed good job hope that
works by the way you don't have to
believe in some kind of conspiracy
theory out there either all you have to
do is check
who's twitter feed yeah okay you should
just look where they're like it's still
up gerald's you're all
bro don't think we'll get to in a second
by the way the blatant lot
look i'm not i'm going to assume that
you didn't blatantly lie in some of the
things that you said
that you're just really lazy or
incapable of your due diligence so you
said some
we'll get to female booker reached out
to you for the show hey gerald have i
ever had a female booker uh that's
that's a no
never ever now you're either lying or
you're so
lazy because i don't want to bully you
and then you go and try and get a swoop
you're so lazy you didn't even just
verify the fact that it was completely
fabricated
all right so now let's go to uh them
doubling tripling
quadrupling down on uh on group
group which by the way and i want to say
this too uh because i from what i
understand ethan's wife is is israeli
and we've talked about the israeli
conflict
defended them of course their right to
exist and i've and i know that you
probably
suffer some anti-semitic comments here
on youtube i've seen them we've received
them just for supporting israel and it's
horrible it's important
but you also understand that israelis
jewish
government agencies sold some people
some [ __ ]
and thank god part of the part of the
influence for the holocaust was using
health guidelines was telling people
that this was for their own public
health safety
i think that the nazis were wrong yes
everyone has
the right to criticize as a matter of
fact everyone tomato tomato
yes tomato gobbles yes
yeah everyone has a required an
obligation
to do their own research you believe
they shouldn't you discourage it
actively
we encourage it actively regardless of
where we line up on our points of view
that's the idea that i'm criticizing
that ethan of course doubled down on
here and it's just
i'm sorry for people watching here who
don't want to have to deal with this
but this is the kind of stuff that your
kids a few of them may be watching
let's watch let's watch
you gotta wear a mask so i'm obviously
wearing them wow big deal
and then now they say you know if you're
outside you don't need to wear a mask
it's pretty simple you want to talk
about dom
yeah i mean there's a whole there's a
whole the cdc is like this whole
governmental body
with scientists and they just tell us
what to do you don't have to think about
it dude
obviously my point is that if you're so
[ __ ] stupid
then yeah you should listen to the cdc
bro
it's there maybe you should like i don't
understand this assumption that he like
we're saying the same thing in a
different tone doctors have spent their
whole life
studying like diseases epidemiology
i mean it makes sense too so i choose to
listen to it you know
it's logical they're not telling me um
go jump off a building and i'm like
well this doesn't make sense but i'll do
it anytime you shut down businesses
they're saying
tell me that it doesn't transmit to
humans with a disease that spreads
taking pills without reading the label
like it's so it's pretty easy
to drop it's not aerosols yeah i kind of
don't have a problem
when you look at ingredients on your
food do you go to the packing uh
plant and and sit and then re-examine
everything
look at the ingredient profile i just
read the ingredients
read the ingredients
i can't believe i wore a master in that
pandemic oh
that was so [ __ ] stupid of me i
should never listen to these scientists
that spent their whole life studying
this
which scientists i got to think for
myself i don't know
i think for myself seriously if this was
at the table next to me i would leave
the restaurant
i think he said you do need to wear wasp
and like he
changed his mind based on the situation
right
based on emails and chinese officials
but you haven't read those you just
trust what the
what the tissue people tell you you
trust that coffee you're drinking you
just changed your mind
you could be making decisions that could
impact your health forever by trusting
that that's coffee
i tasted it out of
the prison that he said they tell you
what to do you don't even have to think
about it dude
look that's not a good rule of thumb for
anything in life
but they act like man it's a gold rule i
mean yeah when you're
as dumb as you that can't understand
[ __ ] you can't pronounce epidemiology
biohazard you should listen to cdc bro
i know that i mean what's the point of
government
if we don't trust these whole
institutions that we've propped up
funded regulated but you don't
blindly trust the government
during a pandemic and with an airborne
virus okay so look let me airborne
yeah airborne again i'm not talking
about droplets look look okay
let's assume let's assume that i'm
as as dumb as you as dumb as you sound
okay well yeah
you could be you know could hey listen
never know spectrum could be really
intelligent as dumb as you sound
right now um let's assume we're both
done
okay this comes down to a world view
let's assume that we're both not doctors
you say we should trust up these
institutions who we've propped up by the
way
we haven't necessarily propped them up
is fauci
was he voted in that's that's one one of
the arguments but i know you haven't
gone that far out from
the trunk into the branches one of the
arguments is you have one of the highest
paid officials in government some of the
most
highly paid officials in government
never held private office and there's
never been an election so to act as
though we should blindly trust these
organizations your world view is
we're so dumb we should trust the world
health organization
who said no human human transmission who
said no way there's a lab leak and then
youtube banned people who suggested it
you're saying
we should blindly trust the cdc because
everyone is too dumb out there you
believe that your audience
is so dumb they couldn't possibly do
their own research and you actively
discourage it so let's assume neither
one of us are doctors
we're both dumb the difference is we
actually provide
sources and references every single day
bring those up right there
cdc world health organization pubmed and
by the way every every single one of
those
every single show you can go to ladder
with cryder.com
go to the go to the actual post of the
video and we provide all these
references below
right we have all of these links below
where you can see and we put them in the
in the description
why because i don't believe that people
should trust me blindly nor the world
health organization
nor the cdc nor anyone my world view is
you should of course
aggregate the word and the advice the
wise counsel
of scientists of medic by the way i
not just fouchy i include doctors who've
seen a patient
well that's like foreign and then verify
it with your own research
also it's not pro science to trust one
person
when about half of the scientific
community for example was saying hey
this thing may have leaked in a lab
scientists from china who some defected
disappeared
right you wouldn't know that but maybe
you could go check out our sources on
our website maybe you'll understand this
a little bit
those scientists were saying one thing
but the organization who you going to
bat for youtube twitter facebook
banned that information from getting out
so it's just two different world views
you believe that your audience is so
dumb they couldn't be trusted with
the ability to research freely that's
the pro-censorship mindset
that permeates the world right now i
believe in discussions with people
regardless of what they believe
and that we provide what a minimum 30
sometimes 120 references per day
yeah almost all neutral like pubmed
scientific journals
or left like new york times you're not
going to find a whole lot of
conservative sources in there
you do it but you're thinking about it
bro you're thinking like if i have a
headache i just go to the medicine
cabinet take whatevs and hope it goes
away kills bro
just take some stuff see what happens
and then he didn't really have a
what are you gonna say i was gonna say i
feel like to rebut him we could have
just played him
when he said when he said listen you
don't have to think about it he's like
no what i meant is that if you're too
stupid
you just need to trust them you're not
dude no you just couldn't you're so
[ __ ]
stupid i don't even know who this guy is
here over there who
he hasn't even done like videos that
used to get millions of plays and now
podcasts would get a few thousand bro
or so you know i don't even know why you
think you should use that portion of
your brain when you
use ten percent i just [ __ ] i'm i use
two percent why would i use ten percent
of my brain
just tell us what to do
what happened to trust but verify trust
but you believe in elitism you believe
that there is a government
savior coming for you in every realm and
that you should listen to them well
that's how authoritarians come to power
why do you think a doctor doesn't
prescribe you some stuff yeah
he's like look i'm just gonna write it
down here whatever
what does it do huh is it by the way
since you're so pro
pharmaceutical company and by the way
we're not anti-vaccines i've talked
about how
many people should get vaccinations
pneumonia
i think then people need to make a
decision i think people have their own
freedoms you know
constitution would be an easy reference
to start with oh um it's a big document
but this idea that i'm anti-vex but
since now all of a sudden you're this
pro-pharmaceutical
company guy well listen the reason that
i do actually ask is because the
commercials say
ask your doctor about abilify you go and
the doctor's like well there's nothing i
can do you're just going to have a
psoriatic arthritis for the rest of your
life
and what about mild to plaque severe
psoriasis what about uh abilify well i
guess we could try that so they tell me
wait you asked my doctor i'm following
those doctors the pharmacist so you know
the point is when you just follow one
person
eventually you know the blind mice get
their tails cut off which should never
be told as a bedtime child
jeffrey dahmer story okay very sad he
sort of mocked me you
you uh and ran out of steam and
got to i guess i guess what is
considered in the youtube world uh
uh a roast there's so much to say
because i haven't really talked about
them
but the dude has such small energy that
he's wearing a holster
he wears a [ __ ] gun holster
he's wearing it as like an accessory
yeah yeah always
yes he wears a gun holes here bro
and he's got tissues next to him in case
you know he starts crying
finish the joke buddy in case you know
there's a premise he starts crying get a
punchline
starts running gendered watch such
beta energy with the [ __ ] cigar the
holster
all these dudes the cigar thing is just
the over compensation it's real does
this guy
dress like marty mcfly or is that
actually an outfit
oh there's laziness again it was a back
to the future themed episode
oh so sick it's so [ __ ] manly to just
have a
big brown turd in your mouth all the
time and a holster
man wait the kleenex let me just say
first of all you have a second
get out of here that's due to allergies
okay
uh so i had a bronchial thing which is
community guidelines in immutable
condition it's genetic
but i guess there's a cease-fire here so
we can talk about any genetic conditions
like the lack of chin
lack of beard 120 pound man wearing the
cinderelly bandana on his head trying to
compensate with the beard that he uses
just for men or the
eyeball phrase like e.t in the cornfield
it's so stupid bro the point is very
active immutable characteristics
uh let's be careful but you were about
to say something you know well you've
always liked cigars you're you're on a
show to promote the
responsible gun ownership yes and then
the it's the same way as they have to
look like wayne and garth transitioning
to kind of be the la uh the further
reach of youtube censorship
to let you you know to kind of put you
in your face now we have to be careful
because i don't know because
they can say you're so [ __ ] so stupid
bro i can't believe you're thinking for
yourself look at him he's got a small
dick but he's the kind of guy who then
goes to youtube and supports
people being banned ethan it's got to
suck to look yourself in the mirror
and know that you've entirely changed
who you are in your content
to appease the powers that be look maybe
you didn't maybe you had a change of
heart where all of a sudden
you don't care about free speech and
expression and you're pro youtube and
you're pro d platforming and your
productization but let's be honest that
one of us here has changed our point of
view and yes i do carry a holster
like many americans tens of millions of
americans why
to promote to to normalize responsible
firearm ownership you know like liberals
with abortions or
or you to you know promote normalizing
the discourage
to the discouraging of of seeking one's
own information and resources
i'm passionate about educating people on
firearm use
you're passionate about people not
educating themselves on anything
different strokes or shaving a patch
if he had just looked into you a little
bit he'd be like oh yeah yeah steven
doesn't need a gun in just about any
street fight he would ever get into
boxing too much jiu jitsu no no that
would be compensating just like cigars
it's not like it's not like an entire
industry of people have enjoyed cigars
passed down for generations because it's
an artistic
product yeah that is delicious no it
must be
because i i have an ethan klein penis
right absolutely it's all pain
you can come after the final time he's
just thinking about your dick
exactly you want to come after us that's
fine just make the arguments
real i don't know that i want you to
come after me and it's not because it's
just that i don't know that eventually
you'll know how to quit me
and now we're back to tips look let me
let me also one thing too that um i want
to say
i'm gonna feel real quick though just as
it it's being
it's essentially just censorship being
disguised as a let's get high and have
fun podcasts
trust he's like doug benson without pot
or movies just nothing right yeah well
look here's one thing too and i want to
say this because we're going to get to
this well you know what first let's go
to the next clip where i guess
he ran out you ran out of steam uh ethan
sorry i keep wanting to say h3h3 but
it's not like your name is ethan it's
just it's not like cher
maybe it is um but uh
something about being conservative
grifter this this is another you know
again this is what you see from the left
don't educate yourself and then ascribe
motive right
here we go i was telling dan i'm like i
wish that i would just be a conservative
it would be like pretty much easy money
it's the easiest griffin
that's like the game every take is so
obvious it's like everyone has the same
opinion
oh i thought it was i thought it was a
bandana it's a it's a wet bandit's beard
yeah wet band
look um okay first off grift
i've been here since 2006 been doing
political videos since 2007 i believe
maybe 2008 on youtube
look there was no money in it okay
regardless can we at least agree that
regardless of where you and i line up
one of us was going upstream here and it
wasn't the guy doing vape nation bro
okay it was wildly unpopular and unlike
yourself
i've never changed who i am this is why
our program is growing and yours isn't
because
people were introduced to your show
through a kind of content and i say this
to everyone out there because
this happens a lot on youtube right you
start with content you have a few viral
videos
and then you say well we can't do this
again hey i know
which way to win podcast i can host it's
like the chocolate rain kid you know
then all of a sudden doing
social justice issue podcasts about you
know like hey zonda
lesbian funk or whatever the hell it is
for affirmative action we're just
sitting there like no it doesn't work
and i and i will say this i have been an
advocate of
new media for a very long time right was
it fox for for for years and obviously
was
stand up dave still does stand up came
up doing that new media i know it's not
new media that term is sort of a
misnomer but
we've lived with it our whole life but i
use that term to frame it new media
versus legacy media you know the scene
on abc's nbc cbs
and i always thought they were wrong i
thought the good part about new media
before the sort of censorship wave was
hey no gatekeepers right people can go
out there
and create content and find their
audience now the downside to that is
there's a billion podcasts and so
when i would have these conversations
with legacy media they would say yeah
the problem there is that any tom dicker
harry can sit down and talk into a
microphone
and they don't understand that we had an
audition process with radio shows and
television shows where you had to be
interesting or
some marketable discernible skill set
that would be valued as some kind of an
entertainment commodity
and when they were saying that look this
is why the new media is never going to
go anywhere they would show
a show like yours and so
in providing resources and sketches and
guests and
you know we'll have a politician we'll
have rudy giuliani on i know you don't
like him but he was mayor of new york
right in times man of the year and then
we'll have
a multiple time uh peer-reviewed
published medical you know scientists
will have an oncologist
we'll have an epidemiologist as the word
that you were looking for
because we want to elevate the platform
you're incapable of it the reason that
legacy media disrespected new media for
a long time it took
is because of content like yours and i
think that's why now
you've become their toady that's why you
have to ingratiate yourself to susan
wojcicki and cnn and vox and
and advocate for the removal and
de-platforming of people because
what else you got look i don't dislike
you i i wanna i criticize an idea
okay you only do youtube pissing
contests with people
it's not what i do that's not what i'm
interested in doing i just think that
it's a bad thing to tell kids
that it's stupid to think about issues
or do your own research yeah well i
disagree with that idea
and so in saying that it's easy money
like it's a grip that's easy do you
understand what demonetization
is yeah which you advocate exactly do
you understand you support
they don't pay us even though sponsors
are ready willing and able to put ads on
our channel they won't let us have it
for even the most benign
hours of research so easy easy
he doesn't do what we do bro which is
put on beanies just sit here
and tell the story with her eyebrows tim
allen lost his show anybody who's even
remotely right-wing in the hollywood
industry has lost
everything get that argument out what an
easy crazy
look yes what an easy grip and yeah it's
all those right-wing specials you see on
netflix
and even though you know you're mr potty
mouth how many strikes
just for actually taking a stand
let's just think about that not hate
speech that's we've never been accused
of hate speech violence just
taking a stand ever willing to take
unpopular opinions
ever willing to swim upstream no instead
and this is where we really differ and
this is where i do think it's actually
shameful because once upon a time
ethan klein would have people for people
out there who know this is a big show on
youtube for peop
other people watching if they're still
watching i know most of them don't care
about this but
they have a lot of young people who tune
in um you would have jordan peterson on
and really you remember quarterback you
used to watch him yeah
back in the day he was really funny he
was one of the few guys who was sort of
anti-sjw censorship yeah yeah
and then flipped yeah his content's
completely different he kind of dropped
off
a totally different person i don't care
if you don't like the totally different
person in that now
you advocate now i've never ever i want
to be clear i don't think your channel
should be demonetized or taken down even
though i think it's really really bad to
tell kids not to do research
i think that's bad i think it's almost
anti-educational
hopefully i pronounce that about as
correctly as you did epidemiologists i
even think
about right is so boring it's
anti-content yes it's fancy content
it's where comedy goes to die
um and bill burr's respect so i think
this is something that is no no his
respect for listen yeah you know i i i
unlike our friend there who's there just
like marty mcfly i've done research on
this program
it is it was very painful that is the
funniest video it was i felt like in
scarface where someone was going you're
going to watch your friend die
no i gotta go to two more hours of this
it's really a clockwork orange i can do
this all night i can do this all night
bro
can't you just develop some form of
narcolepsy and call it a day
so this is the big difference here um i
would
never advocate that you be removed even
though you're espousing
bad ideas um i would never advocate that
other people out there who espouse what
i believe are bad ideas and provide no
substantiation
and frankly bully for a living this is
what he does goes after often smaller
channels
i still think that you have the right to
do it the difference here
is you ethan klein and this is what
happens with liberals
not only lines up with it consistently
supports
active d-platforming demonetizing
and removing points of view which i
don't know how you come up as an
independent
content creator and then do this the
quartering is without a doubt
a social justice warrior except the
causes he fights for
are just different i sentence him to be
banned from twitter
and demonetized 20 billion times
it's the 15 videos it's the misleading
thumbnails
it's the joking about killing her it's
encouraging the audience to go rate her
discord and try to get banned and giving
a cash
prize i mean dude there's this whole
thing of like they came for leafy and
you laughed and next they came for you
and nobody was there it's like dude
no the guys don't see it like that
explain
dude what it is like youtube apparently
for demonetizing him
i think he was locked out of uploading
for a time
but yeah i think at the moment he can
it's just that if he gets another strike
he'll be completely banned from the
platform and so he's
out of an abundance of caution not
uploading got it that's a good idea i
mean i've seen his content
right i mean the one about me was
bordering on covet misinformation
wow like he was flirting with it
there's certain things that joe's been
saying that's like dangerous like the
kovic
like i don't get he's telling his
audience don't get the shot
he's saying masks was for [ __ ] he
literally just
like the other day would you have to
correct what mr
rogan on his podcast yeah he said young
healthy people do
need to get the vaccine now look look
look look this is important here
um i don't know everyone who's talked to
it was a long list we had to shorten
down the montage
people he's attempted to get banned or
removed and maybe maybe some people were
actively
breaking the law you know actually
calling about i don't know yeah
but i do know that doesn't matter sort
of like when people say
abortion what about for incest or rape
and you go oh okay all right
if we allow abortion for incest rape can
we then get rid of all late-term
abortions well no that well then don't
bring it up
right don't bring up that this person
was actually breaking the law with
speech because
you think that it was medical
misinformation
to laugh at you for saying don't even
think about it bro
come on man do you not see the dangerous
march toward fascism
not march you're there you've you've
reached king koopa of fascism
you're jumping over and hitting the key
i can't believe this you think do you
really this is what's so scary is when
you have people
who have the ear of executives at
youtube who get these branding deals
and they say oh it's almost medical
misinformation it's almost medical
misinformation bro to say that
you should think about it
thinking about it would be something
that he should definitely look into
maybe it's different some of the such
stuff that he has oh i think he's super
[Laughter]
i think it's a good show yeah i i i
think it's ridiculous because in that
clip we just played a second ago he
he didn't quite get to this point he's
like yeah i don't i haven't heard of
anybody i think
the second guy i can't i don't know who
he is he's got this monitor over here
somebody else is on there
somebody's on the phone anyway whatever
that is
satan what it could be on speed dial
basically just said you don't get d
platform unless you're like isis and i'm
like
do you understand what like when words
come out of your mouth do you think
about them first or did they just yeah
do you realize that
it's still on twitter and donald trump
isn't do you realize the ayatollah is
still on twitter
and donald trump isn't do you realize
there are there are still beheading
videos that we were removed from youtube
yeah there's there's penis or dildo
videos yeah they're still
not synthetic because he goes yeah
listen it's good to d platform people if
it's like isis but you just said i
borderlined on isis by suggesting people
think or read a label read a label or
quote the cdc depending on the date
oh my gosh that's insane i mean it
really no it's really scary
it's really scary not only because it's
so uh unbelievably um
talentless and unentertaining but it's
scary because you have kids going
okay i won't read well i mean
and making fun of the saying that i hope
that everyone watching this is wearing
those
half hard-boiled egg short helmets well
no and i
i i you know i'm not saying it's the
three most countless people in la i
would never say no no no no
no no but look the whole saying like
that there was nobody left
to help you was built out of an era
where there was nobody left to help
anyone and it was trying to make sure we
didn't get there again and you're a guy
advocating for censorship saying don't
worry about the saying that's supposed
to be helpful
well dude they're not going to come
after him because he's in with the
elites he thinks
well listen well he was roped in for it
because he's you know he's
yeah then i had a lawyer then i had a
lawyer on to say that uh
this is the issue but he had a lawyer on
his shoulder yeah to talk about you
talk about how and they got it again
they got it all wrong so they didn't
even they didn't even get it right as
far as what
what half asian bill has filed and this
is the problem okay this is how rumors
get started
i have a problem with your ideas i want
to be clear about i i have a problem
with
the kinds of concepts that you were
actually espousing and preaching to
young kids okay
i really do but i also want to be clear
here there's a problem
with either you are so lazy that you are
incapable of doing basic research
or you are a compulsive liar
here we go i have an email by the way
from his like
producers one of his producers trying to
get me to come on the show
here i'll read it because there's some
funny excerpts in it so
hi i'm a celebrity talent booker for
louder with crowder
i'd love to book ethan cline ethan
ethan they even bolded my name because
it's a clickbait farm he doesn't even
realize it
please click on it he probably thinks he
has a real letter from santa claus
crowder
is a syndicated show
uh hosted by stephen crowder stand-up
comedian
he was a post for four years on fox news
he was their youngest ever contributor
it said roger ailes even had around with
him
distinctively conservative style has
thrust him
into the national success on most major
cable shows
and then when i didn't respond this
booker was so desperate to get me
she said yes you responded such demand
with fictional books
good morning following up on the below
request can we find a day that works
i'll continue forward me at the original
email again
okay so first of all they emailed him
with a prank call
yes to be clear uh
let me just you know what under penalty
of perjury
gerald uh-huh have i ever had a female
booker uh that would be a no that would
be a no i've never had a female booker
that is either a
lie or again you are so lazy i'm just
gonna say it
so mind-numbingly stupid that you don't
understand or you couldn't be bothered
to do your own basic research that this
comes from a click farm that people use
all the time to try and attach
themselves to famous people
i don't know who that is no one reached
out to you i've never worked with that
person
that's how rumors get started this is
what happens booker reached out
another thing he said steven uh stephen
uh uh ducked out of politicon hey joe
let me ask you
political conferences or festivals
what's my policy you hate them it's like
the plague
of them i hosted cpac for four years
and then never again i think it's been
seven years i did one with yaff as a
favor to a friend
look this is how things get stronger
from politicon
it's like if someone says you want to do
politicon and like you know my dad's my
booger said no it's like
i can call out mike tyson it doesn't
mean he ducked me yeah
oh look he's so desperate to have me on
because this uh this
letter from mrs claus was saying that uh
we want to
it's it's just not true it doesn't exist
well and by the way even if
it didn't happen but if you had reached
out to him he'd basically be
destroying his entire point i want you
to come on the show and say your point
of view
as much as you're terrible you didn't
here's the thing and and i i want to be
really clear about that you have
something you're about to say there dave
oh no i'm just enjoying the show did you
you didn't disguise
yourself as a lady yeah and send out a
mass email with his name clearly
inserted in but
i mean i may have gone on rocket mail
and been like
hey it's like the simpsons crusty camp
work i didn't i hope your kids are
welcome
counselor black to camp krusty
he's like we would love to book ethan
clinton
oh let me spell my name your book is so
stupid bro couldn't you misspell klein
okay and bolded it yeah both of them
i didn't even know his name till just
now right which i guess is another thing
he felt about me he's like oh that is
which is the most meaningless insult you
can possibly get these days yeah
it's like look at your show well that's
what it is look and objectively i will
say look we've talked about this
uh dave land why is dave landau funny
well a because
people think he's people pay money to
see him be funny right people have done
that for a long time professionals pay
money to see him be funny there's humor
is largely subjective right but there
are objective sort of guard rails we've
talked about this where you have
okay objectively right my left your
right you have like richard pryor george
carlin
uh eddie murphy chris dave chappelle
those kinds of people and then you have
objectively people who are
unfunny where nobody likes them the
kinds of people who do open mics for
years at a time and no one else sees
ethan right people like that and then in
the middle
maybe you have your uh you know your
people like your jerry seinfeld's your
richard jennings your gary
your dave landaus or maybe it's not for
you
you aren't for anyone we've just watched
you
just a premise the podcast why does he
have a tissue why does it have a tissue
bro it's like
is it for yes yes is it for
some type of compensation masturbatory
fantasy for donald trump
is it for some kind of uh catching uh uh
we didn't know that aids was aerosoled i
mean just i could write you 15 punch
lines
i'm not saying there'll be gold but at
least we're swinging the bat and i don't
know that you could also physically
swing a bat not accurately
so objectively i just in wanting to
elevate new media and new content which
is why we have guests and sources and
videos and
and sketches research it's more the only
thing offense i know i've offended you
the only thing offensive about you
is the lack of any discernible talent or
skill set whatsoever
but i know that nothing i could say here
could sting nearly as much as you
knowing the dwindling audience who no
longer respects you because of a 180
on your world view i'm sure the shame
that you feel is
punishment enough but i am benevolent so
look i will say this time i'll have my
actual booker
my dad write a joke about he can do it
who's dead bro yep
yep my dad works for me isn't it yeah
yeah because your wife is on a show my
dad actually
worked in relations worked in
in in customer relations and booking
before i don't know that your wife has a
resume of
hosting if she does good well you're
you're dead
so proud of you and still wants to speak
with you this is true i'm not saying
that might be different for other people
i'm just i have no idea that's entirely
conjecture
but if i had to bet bro i wouldn't even
have to think about it so
look i will say this uh i will never
ever after this address you again
because
i do feel like you're trying to bait
people out there trying to bait us into
getting into a
back and forth youtube pissing contest
where we never actually meet in person
and never actually have a conversation
and i just usually so i'm going to
assume that you're not lying because
i never give debates or interviews to
people who lie
right right like hey he said he was
going to meet me at the town square no i
didn't i'm not going to give an
interview i'm not going to be baited
that
that way i think you got an email and
you're dumb i don't think you lied i
think that you actually believed
that a booker reached out to you but
it's incredible a celebrity booker right
a celebrity booker yeah yeah just so you
know it's i'm a celebrity in the email
people know who i am
he was unlike dave linda he was fooled
by the email equivalent of a talk boy
this is peter mcallister calling the
father
yeah yeah did it end with see you later
you filthy animal
yes did he sing cool cat
so i will invite you on the show
uh ethan klein i will have my you know
i'll follow you on twitter i will have
darren my booker reach out where you can
come on this show and by the way
i will always be respectful i will never
interrupt there's a difference between
what we do here i
will just be me you and i and we can
discuss the difference in our worldview
that
you don't believe you don't believe in
providing references sources and you
think it's stupid to think critically
of any sort of governmenting body i
disagree with you and i think it's a bad
message
to teach kids you think it's really bad
that i responsibly carry a firearm
let's talk about the issues you you come
on my show i would never
i would never invite myself onto your
show but either way whatever you're
comfortable with
an even playing field no editing you and
i can talk about it
it is appointed to a man once to be
invited on this show
gerald knows his policy as well he'll
get this invitation
once it's not like you can come back
later two years down the line and say oh
i'll take that no no just like someone
said hey i'll save this car for 20
thousand dollars you don't get to come
here two years from now say i'll take
that car
the offer is once we'll reach out you
can come on to this show
or i'll go on your show if you want me
to to discuss the issues i guarantee you
that i will keep it respectful as i
always have with anyone we've debated
whether it's a pulitzer prize winner
or a scientist or a mayor doesn't matter
who it is um
i'll make sure that we we have a civil
discussion and if you don't if you
decline and everyone now knows that you
will
you can keep talking about me if you
want but i will never address you again
because i have no interest in going back
and forth with um
the kind of hackery that takes place
there so all right that's really all i
have to say about that
yeah uh and i hope uh you know i hope he
takes me up on it he's gonna have to
think it'll be interesting
i just like to meet him he seems like a
good guy
the kind of guy you could have a beer
with you know yeah you know just really
enjoy the conversation a vape with bro i
don't drink beer because i get a
headache bro
yeah and then i just take whatever yeah
so the doctor says take this and i wake
up and i'm really
i'm really [ __ ] sore bro he's a
doctor i watched the video for this by
the way and i was
shocked that a million people have been
duped into subscribing
well you know i will say this like he
had content that was good before yeah
that's what i'm saying
he's got a lot of those are like kind of
comfortable by the way let me just say
this too people hey the best thing you
can smash that like button yes
people out there who are watching right
now and we're about to go to muk club
only we'll do this segment on the esg
scores we'll keep photoshop or not for
tomorrow
and comment comment what you would if
you would like to see this out there
because i know a lot of you don't necess
you're not familiar with this
person if you would like to see that
conversation and please
if you go over to ethan kline's channel
i i don't advocate that you do
keep it respectful keep it civil show
them who we are
because we don't want to be trolls we
actually want to have conversations and
we also like to have
uh we like to have a left but oh my gosh
could you imagine just just like you
don't even have to think about it bro
bill cosby can you imagine how much he
would just beam
from ear to ear if someone said that
he'd like oh ho stay out stay over here
i'll go get a doctor
and show everything he's a doctor he
said he says to drink the coffee yes he
should drink the coffee
oh it's a scientist so i'm gonna think
about it bro and he would just look at
the camera
yeah detectives showed up at their next
house there's a smell coming from under
your porch and he's like
yeah you really got to go digging around
though right yeah yeah just trust me
this is good enough
good enough for me it's a hot summer
yeah good enough for me all right
uh hey listen we actually have a whole
segment here we didn't get to oh okay
yeah uh
on the esg scores are people familiar
with this
i don't know if they are okay so this is
actually um i want to make sure that i
get this
we're doing that in the mud club though
yeah we're doing it on mod club so it's
a social credit score for businesses out
there
uh we'll be talking about this a little
bit but actually um these huge ceos are
a part of
and of course climate change the woke
agenda lgbtq
um all of this is a part of a lot of
these fortune 500 companies
and it's pretty scary so um we're going
to talk about it i don't know that this
is the kind of thing people would
it wouldn't be a problem on youtube but
who knows maybe ethan klein will make a
couple of calls and then we see that
uh right now thank you so much for
people who are watching on youtube
people aren't we have another hour of
show loudworthcrowder.com
mug club uh and we'll be taking your
chats youtube
[Music]
episode
[Music]